I think she was a typist or like
a receptionist and she was working down
there in this in this sea station. Well.
I was when the department of representatives
down there and got the over the phone
. One night i got the. Got the yellow alert
that was the red the green and the and
which meant you had to get out was fast as
you could. So this is about two o'clock
in the morning so i did nothing really.
Said yellow alert and i knew what that
meant i had to when you get down to
the bottom ground floor bowels and
so away i know there were no taxis. There
were no buses there was no nothing. Say
a cushion and then
membered. Oh gosh there's
a spare my truck down the manly bus depot
hollering up the whole ring up the
bloke in charge down there telling her i
wasn't going to have his truck to get over
sydney i have urgent i had to go in
a hurry. So he said look i know what
you're talking about. I know what you're
talking about he said the tracks elsewhere.
So i said. What i'd do to get i got to
get out of the straightaway. He said leave
it to me leave it to me. I said. Right.
I believe it. You know he seemed fairly
confident within about ten minutes
a quarter and how there was
a double decker bus pulled up
outside. So. I got broken that
always that the buses waiting for you. So
i day were over to town in this double
decker bus. Well that was all right. I
went down to be did what i had to do. Down
came home later on but when i got back
to the office. Louise chief traffic
management. He was calling for your i got
me on the intercom and he was robel what
i'd done i'd take the bus out of service
and manley would bus services in many
cases but i'd take them so he said why going
to the commissioner i'll tell you this
is absolutely unthinkable i'm just here
frank manager that was my you know all the
rubbish they go on. So i said right oh
that's the best thing you can do then you go
ahead. So about half an hour later there's
a bus. I wish this message. Are waiting
and he said look mr pizza commissions
waiting for you would you come up and see
him sort i preside now. Went up their
mobility said he said you took
a bus out of service morning mr police.
I said yes i didn't just i commend your
action very much. But said it right down
the ground. What the other bloke right
over because i didn't like it really goes.
So there i think about it but what did
you have to go down there for anyway i
was departmental representatives. And
part of the part of the arrangements were
that the wardens in charge of particular
areas in the event of an emergency
happening. Had to get in touch with their
headquarters filling or forward over the
fire and these girls on the other end
would would fill it and type
them out and people or all this.
To think. They had
a u-shaped table and the
message was read comsec.
Get sick. It really is. You went right
and anything very important which would
affect their department they who were in
direct telephone communication direct line
to that and you then report to the department.
What it was you thought that way.
Should now go out and take the
necessary action. From then on in
the years to have these to
have these these. Mock fairs
and everybody come in
a way to put it past the bond i junctions
are blown up or something like that. The
moment the middle of central station but
anybody or any consequence had to to pick
out what was interesting. Let them
know. Well you know this involves
a lot of time as they have to get messages
over all over the and these typists
i who i believe principally employed
by the railway department was typists.
No one of them on the upper
floor a couple of off for
a long winded house where the railway station
is now they were slip on their health
just released this week cases like that.
So these girls had been pulled out
a bit about two o'clock in the morning and
they came down into this conference room
and you never saw more drag women fight in
all your life i've been pulled out of it
. I haven't had time to get dressed like.
Dressing gowns and hair all over the
place you know. Completely
absence of what about you
might be you must look pretty terrible to.
Oh yes we probably i got. Straight out
a bit i stated i mean a
race should look like
a cuppa tea. That's seen
a piece of cake by the silence plus it
turned up and i got to go to work and.
Do you remember the day that the of the
submarine attack were you were in the
committee at that time. Yes yes yes i was
down there defend out after what it was
all about. But you weren't actually down
there during the attack. I don't know
you don't know would get the alarm i mean
right well that well they were i don't
know i i got to know more about that.
Laughter. Well that sounds like what happened
then. Because judith writes that she was
on duty down there at time and they didn't
know to let came up. Well
i didn't know about it.